on this episode I talk about influencers
I talk about the law and we hear fire
engines you keep asking questions I'll
keep trying to answer them
[Music]
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
you're watching the askgaryvee show
episode number 28 fun fact about the
number 28
that is AJ's birthday January 28 and
this is the single number that I made
the most money on roulette in my entire
life
so obviously a couple episodes ago we
did a live audience kind of play when I
was at an event so I decided to try it
out one more time right behind the piggy
back a little quick note I know a bunch
of you expect me to be really sad since
I was sad a couple episodes ago after
Jets loss and the Jets lost 31 to
nothing yesterday but Steve as you know
very close to the prediction I made of
37 7 you're noticing a happy energy
today because here's the difference a
lot of you who sat through Wine Library
TV years and the Jets know that when I
decide the seasons completely over
actually not that upset I've hit my pain
point I'm dead and now I'm really
looking on to next year so from here on
out I won't be that grumpy alright got
some dudes together for today's show so
somebody just jumped right in let's get
right into it your name Kyle coming Kyle
say hello to the vaynernation everybody
I'm Kyle with Locker dome I run a brand
partnerships at Locker dome awesome you
can reach out to me in Locker dome comm
/ Kyle Cummings I like the plug Kyle go
ahead what's your question yeah
absolutely so you've been in the
influencer space for just over a year
specifically the great wave story and
with that business model what are the
biggest challenges you're facing and
scaling that business model and what is
the the brand that you would say is
embracing that model for marketing with
mobile and those channels Twitter
snapchat and Instagram specifically
which brands are doing a good job in
those channels using influencers yeah I
think a lot of brands are starting to do
it well right like any bring that's not
doing it well is losing but I think our
GE client was first to jump did a really
good job Virgin Mobile's done a really
good job
I think hewlett-packard right now
Samsung there's a lot of brands I think
that are getting the value of influencer
the problem with scaling my businesses
were a
Allen agency right and so these guys get
and gals get built up we build up with
them and they get too big and they want
to go to CIA or things that that nature
and so unlike niche which is an
investment I that's building technology
and a platform you guys like there's
people that are doing it smarter than me
the model issue for me is you know it's
just client service it's just people you
only have the leverage for so long but
it's no different than CIA or William
Morris if you're the best and you're
good at it there's a real business there
but that is clearly the challenge to
make this an overarching question for
everybody when you decide to build a
model where you're not building an asset
which is technology or something that
nature you're only vulnerable to your
sources it's being an accountant or a
lawyer or an agency you're only as good
as your last billing cycle and that's
why those businesses don't get them hire
multiple that's why people want to build
technology companies for me I love
people and so I'm always gonna have a
competitive advantage betting on my
strengths which is people interaction so
I like building those businesses but I
got to tell you something it's really
not for everybody and there's definitely
a huge vulnerability in cool man thanks
for stopping by next let's go get in
here let's go here we go awesome hey I'm
Jordan Moran don't a huge fan of yours
since the Wine Library days thanks
brother thank you for having of course
say a lot of vaynernation hello guys hey
Steve so my question for you is I am
transitioning to a new project
management roles
yep company ok um how do you maintain
having high standards with your team
making sure things get done but still
keeping the project on time and on
budget
I wish Aaron bear was here from
vaynermedia because he's ahead of all
that at vaynermedia he's killing it you
know I think it takes humanity I think
the answer is humidity I actually think
the best way to be a great project
manager or get things done is to be a
great listener
instead of talker right you go into this
new role I see with a lot of my project
management people they're organized
they're good but they want to talk it to
success I actually think it's the drop
down flip it in reverse it I think it's
a Missy Elliott structure I think the
way you win is by listening to the
people of to why they're not doing well
why are they two weeks behind if you
haven't actually apply empathy and
understand what's going on there you
become known to everybody as the project
manager that gets it
and so I I say you walk in with not your
architecture and organization and like
I'm gonna guide this you're gonna guide
it with your ears more than your mouth
and that is something most project
management oriented people only learn
later in life and realize is the key
factor thanks for those kind words I'm
glad you got on all right next let's go
let's keep this going
there you go max max real pleasure say
it what's that stuff so I co-founded a
company called shimmer and we're just
getting much ass that's wrongly for
social media floats or space okay it's
like as you know you work for this space
it's really wrong yep so what do you
like the biggest opportunities are there
currently untapped in the social media
influencers yeah I like obviously
there's Brandon Caesars against all that
stuff but like where do you think like
the next you know I guess like the next
big thing can be in the space I'm gonna
go overarching I know we already had an
influence for questions so I like how
this is working
were you like holy crap you asked if you
sleep yeah well I gotta go first yeah to
me this is the biggest thing that people
don't understand about the influence
social space not only do influencers
create content they create distribution
so for the first time ever in one entity
you get both things that people want you
know if you think about television
production companies or movies Steven
Spielberg but then you need distribution
right so what I would say is the biggest
opportunities for these guys for you for
me for everybody's playing in the space
is to recognize that unique principle in
today's internet world where they they
actually can drive to things and then
apply them the other
place that I think there's a huge
opportunity to answer your question to
give everybody more information go
little deeper as I've been trying to go
his product I think that the infomercial
space the leveraging of like you know
celebrity into product like I at one
point could have easily sold tens of
thousands of glassware sets because of
my wine influence I think retail and
product call it QVC 3.0 is another place
that people need to think about ok
thanks brother good luck to you thanks
stay well next let's go Gary hey man I'm
Ashish I'm co-founder of a startup
company called La trades and we're a
marketplace for legal services a lot of
my question is is you advise startups
you invest in startups but when startups
become inherently competitive with other
companies yes Tom what's your biggest
advice to stay ahead of the game is it
just to give more value than the person
behind you or down your back you know I
default as an entrepreneur thinking it's
always gonna be competitive you know
like I love when people are like
nobodies in our space I'm like great
because if you're good everybody's gonna
be in your space right like if you
figured something out you're gonna have
plenty of competitors you know to me
it's the same old game right like it's
better execution it's better product
it's better service it's better
everything that's going to actually
drive your business so I can't give a
blanket answer here this is why
vaynermedia works in a world of
askgaryvee and me putting out content i
can give you general stuff I'm trying to
go deeper and give you more stuff with
this format but I need to know who your
competitors are so for you your business
are they bigger entities with more money
well you when you're when you're David
you don't play Goliath's game so when
you're Goliath destroy David like like
that matchup should have it should have
never gotten to the slingshot just
squish that guy right and so I to give
the practical advice it's got to be
something here's example back to depth
something I'm trying to challenge myself
in this show was anybody else surprised
as hell that I barely talked about
vaynermedia for three years like for
somebody that's always out there
promoting you notice if you went to
vaynermedia's website for the last two
three years that it was like nothing
there because I was
and I needed to make sure that the
bigger agencies didn't realize how big I
was actually getting that was my
competitive play in a competitive
landscape now that I'm getting a little
bit bigger I'm getting a little bit more
out there I'm putting myself more out
there because I have the leverage of
having more money to hire the best
talent or acquire the biggest clients so
the answer to your question is
completely predicated on where you are
in your life cycle versus your
competitors life cycle and what I would
tell you is and here's where I can give
the most tangible answer though still
theoretical never play the other
person's game that's where everybody
gets like oh that big guy or gal is now
running ads we're gonna to problem they
have ten million dollars you put eighty
thousand dollars yeah you lost yeah and
so it's never played the other person's
game cool they said real pleasure to
meet you finally
I warned it Charlie Charlie nice to meet
you a pleasure guys pretty quick
question but what's your stance on
investing in competitive companies
meaning if you like for me as a fund you
as a fan you individually guys it's not
useless audience it's just as a horn
nobody in the vaynernation is concerned
about a horn cell people hear the word
do you think they'll be able to hear the
words can we hear the word I get it and
I love you supporting your teammate
d-roc and I I see what you're doing I
love this support but that horde this
this this fire truck is adding to the
ambience of the fact that we're sitting
in New York City like we're not sitting
in our normal rule they'll deal with it
right the erotic alright thank you it
pains you right it's like the editor and
you just like can't deal with them now
the horrors are coming you're just yeah
this is just pouring it on you we're
sticking with it so if I'm a fund and
I'm for example when I was an investor
in gowalla and there was a chance to
invest in Foursquare I didn't but I know
people that have invested in similar
companies are you asking me like to put
my VC hat on yeah an angel hat you know
look I think there's two answers one I
think if you're investing in a company
and then there's a chance to invest in
somebody who's a direct competitor and
that company wants you to do that that
seems like a
that seems that seems to me like a
little bit of a dick move what I'm more
worried about is the problem I'm facing
now I'll be quiet for you this is me
doing the nice thing for you but the
tape is running the tape is running
better to me the bigger problem is the
pivot right now my biggest problem is
I'm investing in companies that are a
little bit different but I can see as an
entrepreneur how one move by each
product gets them into a competitive
space my answer is you go in with the
open eyes and honesty that you can but
you can't fight against the fact that
people are competing with each other as
we now live in a world where the cost of
entry to compete with each other is so
much lower I think you should go in with
the right intentions your reputation by
the way the only reason I think you
should be a good guy or gal and not
invest in the competitor is because your
reputation is your equity they could
selfish it's because I want to be able
to invest in things in the future and if
I have a reputation for constantly
investing in my competitive stuff just
to win on short term money I'm not gonna
be able to get into deals so I think
reputation management in a transparent
world matters I think that is a dick
move if you're doing that graduate do is
that basically answering a question why
did you ask that question is that
something you're saying it's kind of
curious I co-founded a start-up with Max
and sometimes we kind of run into that
problem like people say no sorry they
already invested in like a similar
company do you view them as a direct
competitor when they say on paper they
see it as a competitor but when you dive
into it it's not well that's where you
guys just have to do a better job in
educating people how it's different
gotcha
thank you appreciate you guys guys
episode 28 in a bag there's some fire
engines in the background that if you
would have seen the I we need to go to a
second screen environment cuz if they
would have watched e rocks pinging Zach
you got his pain I need some of that
pain out there appreciate the questions
today lot about influencers I appreciate
that guys question of the day who's the
biggest influence to you right now that
is not in your inner circle outside
influence not family we just did that
not your mom your grandpappy who raised
you biggest influence right now outside
of your inner circle that's a new
influence in the last 24 months you keep
asking questions I'll keep answering
them
on this episode I talk about Kickstarter
Twitter Facebook and finally ello